aggressions it took the colombian
government 20 years to recognize part of
the state's responsibility in the case
of jeanette bedoya
the colombian journalist was abducted
tortured and raped while investigating
an armed trafficking network between
paramilitaries and colombian state
officials in 2000
in the name of the columbia state i
recognize our international
responsibility for the failings of the
judicial system
that did not realize a worthy penal
investigation for the victim
and i offer an apology to jeanette
wadoya for the damage it caused
jeanette has campaigned for two decades
to bring her attackers to justice
for her the government's acknowledgement
is another slap in the face
this is a case where part of the
evidence has been lost where my mother
and i have constantly been threatened
with witnesses have been threatened and
killed and where to this day those who
threaten me
say i will be raped again a full apology
requires recognizing that these cases
are not investigated at all
and the states offers no support to
women who suffered the worst possible
violence
was kidnapped in front of police
officers on may 25th
2000 by a group of right-wing
paramilitaries outside a prison in
bogota
and then tortured and raped for 16 hours
before being abandoned
on the side of a road she says prison
guards and the police were involved
and an army general and a police chief
were behind the attack
among others her captors at the time
told her the assault was a direct
message to the press
the case has long lagged in colombia's
justice system
while bedoya has become the symbol of
all women and journalists
fighting against impunity in the country
attacks on journalists and women
continue just like 20 years ago
impunity remains higher than 98 in these
cases
so it's very difficult to believe the
state when it says it's committed in the
fight on crimes against journalists and
women
when clearly it is not the case these
are not failings of a particular moment
in time
they are structural
three former paramilitaries have been
convicted for the attack recently
but none of the masterminds and now the
case reached the inter-american court
for human rights
the court's decision which is definitive
and unappealable
is expected in november and could set a
precedent for
thousands of journalists and victims of
sexual violence
hoping to see justice prevail alessandro
al-jazeera bogota